Quelle est la menace la plus importante pour la santé des Américains ?
Le cancer ? Les crises cardiaques ? Le diabète ?
En fait, ce n'est aucune des trois ;
c'est la maladie d'Alzheimer.
Toutes les 67 secondes,
une personne est diagnostiquée porteuse d'Alzheimer aux États-Unis.
Alors que le nombre de victimes d'Alzheimer va tripler d'ici 2050,
prendre soin d'eux, mais aussi du reste de la population vieillissante,
va vite devenir un défi sociétal insurmontable.
Ma famille a vécu de près
la difficulté de la charge d'une victime d'Alzheimer.
Ayant grandi auprès de 3 générations,
j'ai toujours été proche de mon grand-père.
Quand j'avais 4 ans,
nous nous promenions dans un parc au Japon,
quand mon grand-père s'est perdu.
Ce fut l'un des moments les plus effrayants de ma vie.
Ce fut aussi le premier signe nous informant
que mon grand-père était atteint d'Alzheimer.
Ces dernières 12 années, son état s'est dégradé progressivement,
et en particulier, ses fugues ont été une source d'anxiété pour ma famille.
Ma tante, la principale personne l'aidant,
s'est battue pour veiller la nuit et le surveiller,
et malgré tout échouait souvent à le voir se lever.
J'ai commencé à m'inquiéter du bien-être de ma tante,
et de la sécurité de mon grand-père.
J'ai cherché intensivement une solution pour aider ma famille.
Mais je n'en ai pas trouvé.
C'est alors, qu'une nuit, il y a deux ans,
alors que je surveillais mon grand-père, je l'ai vu se lever de son lit.
Au moment où il a mis le pied au sol,
j'ai pensé, pourquoi ne pas fixer un capteur de pression à son pied ?
Dès qu'il pose un pied au sol et sort du lit,
le capteur de pression détecterait la pression de son poids
et enverrait un signal sur le téléphone de l'aidant.
Ainsi, ma tante peut dormir la nuit,
sans s'inquiéter des fugues éventuelles de mon grand-père.
Je vais vous faire une démonstration de mes chaussettes.
Voici mon mannequin.
Merci.
Dès que le patient met les pieds au sol -
(Sonnerie)
une alarme sonne sur le téléphone de l'aide-soignant.
Merci. (Applaudissements)
Merci mademoiselle.
Voici un dessin de mon premier modèle.
J'ai opté pour une technologie basée sur les capteurs
parce que cette technologie me passionne depuis toujours.
Quand j'avais 6 ans,
un ami âgé de ma famille s'est gravement blessé
en tombant dans sa salle de bain.
J'ai pensé à mes grands-parents,
et j'ai créé une salle de bain intelligente,
avec des capteurs de mouvements installés dans les pavés de la salle de bain.
Ils détecteraient la chute des personnes âgées.
Je n'avais que 6 ans.
Je n'étais pas encore à l'école primaire.
Je n'avais pas les ressources nécessaires pour concrétiser mes idées.
Cependant, ces expériences ont ancré en moi le désir profond
d'utiliser des capteurs pour aider les personnes âgées.
Je suis persuadé que les capteurs peuvent améliorer leur bien-être.
En dessinant mes plans, j'ai découvert 3 défis :
d'abord, développer les capteurs,
ensuite, concevoir le circuit,
et développer l'appli du smartphone.
J'ai compris à ce moment que mon projet était plus complexe
que je ne le pensais.
Il fallait d'abord créer un capteur portable
suffisamment flexible pour être confortable aux pieds.
J'ai testé des matériaux différents, comme le caoutchouc.
Mais c'était trop épais pour être porté sur des chaussettes.
J'ai imprimé une membrane avec des particules d'encre
conductrices d'électricité et sensibles à la pression.
Celle-ci augmente la connectivité entre les particules.
Cela m'a permis de développer un circuit qui mesure la pression
en mesurant la résistance électrique.
Ensuite, j'ai du créer un circuit sans fil et portable.
Le problème est que les transmissions sans fil sont énergivores,
et requièrent des batteries encombrantes.
La solution était dans le Bluetooth que j'ai découvert à ce moment.
Ça consomme peu d'électricité, et une pile bouton suffit.
Le système ne s'arrête plus au milieu de la nuit.
Enfin, j'ai dû développer l'appli pour le smartphone de l'aidant
pour le transformer en télé-surveillance.
J'ai donc approfondi mes connaissances en langage de programmation, Java, Xcode,
et en programmation pour les dispositifs associés au Bluetooth.
J'ai regardé des formations sur Youtube et lu des manuels.
J'ai réussi à intégrer les composants en deux prototypes.
Le premier est un capteur intégré sur une chaussette.
Le deuxième est un capteur ré-attachable.
Il adhère à toutes les surfaces entrant en contact
avec les pieds du patient.
Je teste ce dispositif depuis un an avec mon grand-père.
Le taux de réussite est de 100%.
Le système a détecté plus de 900 tentatives de fugue.
L'été dernier, j'ai testé une version bêta
dans plusieurs maisons de retraite en Californie.
Je suis en train d'analyser les résultats
pour améliorer le système et en faire un produit vendable.
A travers ces tests, je me suis rendu compte
que certains patients ne portent pas de chaussettes la nuit.
Je dois donc développer un système pour eux aussi.
Les données collectées par les capteurs
peuvent servir à améliorer les soins des patients,
et pourraient contribuer à aider la guérison.
Par exemple, j'étudie pour le moment
la corrélation entre la fréquence des fugues
et l'hygiène de vie des patients.
Je n'oublierai jamais mon système détectant pour la première fois
mon grand-père en train de sortir de son lit.
Cet instant m'a fait comprendre que la technologie
a la capacité d'améliorer nos vies.
Des gens heureux et en bonne santé -
voilà mon rêve pour un monde meilleur.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)